hey everybody and welcome to the
greatest wild ride of all time i think i
can safely say that this guest is the
most requested most in-demand guest that
we could possibly get that's right it's
johnny knoxville the main star of the
number one movie in the world right now
jackass forever which
is still in theaters and really could
use a visit from you this weekend but
man i'm so excited this episode we get
into every little detail of the things
that were not allowed to be shown on
jackass and that's right it gets very
very juicy so i want to start this just
like i start every single day
which is with athletic greens yes man my
diet has kind of gone to hell and i'm
not getting enough greens and i really
don't want to become unhealthy so i go
for one scoop of this stuff and in every
single scoop i've got
75 vitamins minerals
whole food sourced superfoods probiotics
and did all kinds of good stuff and it
tastes absolutely delicious when i get
done
drinking it with my with my water in the
morning i'm totally hydrated i've got
all the nutrients i need for the whole
day and i feel great about it because
this stuff is absolutely delicious
telling you i live by it i swear by it
and i love it and i want you to try it
too plus dude get a load of this if you
go to athleticgreens.com
stevo they're going to give you an
entire year's supply of immune boosting
vitamin d
and five free travel packets of ag-1
which is what i use every morning
so
look out for your health man become
healthier and fill in the gaps in your
diet take care of your your gut health
your
dig your overall health get on down to
athleticgreens.com
stevo now let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen johnny knoxville
yeah dude yeah dude you know scott
randolph and the gorgeous paul briskey
yes yes hello
people have been begging for this one
this podcast is going to
do unbelievably well oh well we hope so
yeah
um
so yeah dude um
but
we recently had this awesome time
i was sitting down with the hollywood
reporter telling uh the oral history of
jackass i had a blast doing that yeah
that was funny but
i didn't come away
uh
i always understood that your story was
that like right out of high school you
moved to l.a to go become a big movie
star
yeah like um well a month out of high
school i moved out to los angeles to
attend the american academy dramatic
arts
and
for a six weeks program that was my
excuse to have my parents let me go to
los angeles and i attended the first two
weeks and
didn't go back because i was 18 in los
angeles and i was just partying so much
uh
and
spent the summer out here ran through
all my money
and
my parents convinced me to come home
and uh
i went home for a few months
worked at a restaurant
made some more money and came back
for good in january of 90.
okay when you're working at the
restaurant were you filming stuff or
were you just working knocks on that was
a busboy
but like you weren't like because
when did that video of you with the
shooting yourself in the chest that was
like 95
yeah 95 96. probably shot in 95 and came
out in 96. yeah something like that yeah
that that whole bit of like self-defense
was all included in that
or maybe shot 96 came out in 97 but yeah
that was the first time you ever had
filmed anything right
and i wasn't even going to film it right
i was going to just write an article and
tremaine suggested i film it as i always
understood it your story
and i describe it that way is like the
bad company
song shooting star is that kind of fair
to say like
well i i i mean
well there were a lot of pills and
whiskey beside my bed
at one time uh but yeah i mean that
that's your version of it that's that's
wonderful
yes i i love it i mean like john says
johnny was a schoolboy when he heard his
first beatles song but like it's like
when you were a schoolboy you decided
you wanted like you were in love with
the movies
right i remember when we were filming
the first jackass movie you had this
like i think it was on your ipod you had
like old school
uh like classical movies like that you
were listening just the audio of it and
i was like what are you doing oh right
right like the theme song the cinema
paradiso or or uh bits from casablanca
yeah i love it yeah i mean like it was
crazy it wasn't music it was like you're
listening to the actual scene just the
yeah just the audio of scenes from
movies yes and i was like so confused by
that and you were like hey man i love
movies yeah
that's how my family
we
ate around the television i'm either
watching television like samford and sun
or the andy griffith show or watching
films yeah so that's how we connected
you're just going from there and it's my
version of your story but it's like you
know you know
you say mom i'm going to go away i'm
going to be a big star you go out to l.a
and uh
and don't do [ __ ] for the first six
years besides i studied a little but
mostly i was partying and spinning my
wheels i mean i knew you i know you
wanted to be a big movie star and uh and
you did find some success in television
commercials
right well when my then girlfriend got
pregnant we had a daughter on the way
that was
the point in my life where i decided i
have to do something
so i just started trying to make
anything happen any positive step
forwards uh so my friend john linson got
me a job writing for magazines like
bikini magazine and
which is now defunct and my next-door
neighbor at the time was antoine fuqua
and he helped me get a commercial agent
and
it's funny because
i never really got
call backs before i started writing for
magazines but when i started writing for
magazines it took the pressure off i'm
like well i'm i can do this so i don't
have to lean so heavy on this and it
relaxed me on the auditions and i
started getting call backs constantly
nice yeah
there was less desperation there
yes less nervousness i had such a fear
of talking on camera like i remember
i wanted to be in i decided in high
school i wanted to move out to los
angeles and be in the movies and
we filmed something they filmed
something at my high school my junior
year it was something about i don't know
they filmed us talking about nutrition
and everyone else was like really good
on camera and i was terrified i couldn't
even say anything
so it took me a long time to get over
that fear of talking on camera hmm were
you were you terrified of talking on
camera jackass the first season no you
had it he had it by then you had it yeah
yeah no i
like by the time uh
i filmed the self-defense equipment bit
uh like you're probably totally
comfortable yeah yeah but when you're
like so you get the job writing for big
brother i will say i'll come back to
this sir
with my friends filming yeah i would
still get nervous walking on a hollywood
movie set
thinking
i'm gonna get fired at any second like
the read-throughs
i thought you were more funny like the
ringer
no
i like the ringer that's why you're
wearing theaters i like so what was your
uh i was just gonna say like uh because
i never really thought of it this way
but when you're writing for big brother
in your head are you still like i'm just
going to do this
while i try to become a serious actor
like the whole time this was like kind
of for sure just like a day job while
you're still pursuing being i was yeah i
was trying to pursue both whatever click
first that's what i wanted cool okay
yeah and and uh
so
you've got some television commercials
going you're you're writing for mags but
you really like
as i understand it
my version of your story is that you
just kind of felt like okay man i'm
gonna now it's time to really make
something happen i'm gonna i'm gonna put
myself on the map and that was kind of
what the self-defense equipment was it
was like a big thing to just
get get the attention get the ball going
oh man we're about to hear how johnny
knoxville's rise to stardom truly began
and i bet you've never seen him or me
with any facial hair because we always
like to keep a nice clean shave
and if you're looking for a nice clean
shave for a very reasonable price boy do
i have an exciting deal for you because
i swear by these products from harry's
i've been using them for years now it's
just good quality the best quality you
can get no gimmicks
nothing but just a
killer razor and for first time
customers of carriers if you're going to
take advantage of this opportunity you
get this starter kit it comes with a
five blade razor a weighted ergonomic
handle foaming shave gel and a cool
travel case to protect your blades when
you're on the road and man i love it
dear i always have a good clean shave
and i love my hairs if you go to
harrys.como you get this starter kit
which is a 13 value but you're only
gonna pay three bucks telling you you
can't beat it i love it so go to harry's
dot-com that's h-a-r-r-y-s
dot com slash devo to pounce on this
deal because you're gonna love it now
let's hear about johnny knoxville's big
break
and so
you've got this idea and you're gonna do
a product review of self defense
equipment with the
the red pepper spray point blank in the
eyes the stun gun the taser gun
and and what the world didn't know about
was the the smith and wesson 38 caliber
handgun the plan was you're going to
shoot yourself
with a bulletproof vest on and then
people don't know that because mtv
wouldn't show that part but uh that's
really the pivotal moment where
everything
like that's like the
the thing
yeah that's what
clicked for me um and i felt like
also
when i got to big brother
i felt like it was a special group of
guys
and but the self-defense equipment was
the first
time in my life where i felt like i had
momentum
yeah
did did you uh were you introduced to
big brother in a professional capacity
before the self-defense equipment i met
jeff on a video that spike was directing
for uh a ban for wax right okay
and i only remember this because
the date because
it was the day of the oklahoma city
bombing we're on the set and we heard
that we're like oh jesus
so that stuck in my head that that's the
first day i met jeff
and
i think a year or so goes by and i went
down to world industries to meet with
them because i was writing for mags by
that point and but i had it was a
skateboarding magazine and i didn't have
any idea what to write for a
skateboarding magazine because i didn't
skate
so
it wasn't until i had the self-defense
equipment idea that i was like oh maybe
that's something they might like right
oh man
and then
i remember
seeing you in big brother magazine with
the the first the self-defense and then
like then in the bowl ring like you were
doing stuff with bowls just for the
pages of big brother
yeah i was just trying to think of ideas
but
the
i was disappointed in myself that day
uh because i went up to gary the fuse
ranch
in nepal california
and i got on the so-so bowl
right
he had other bulls but i got on a social
bull and i felt like a real failure
right and and after that because he said
he had a bull up there named mr mean
that like even the cowboys hated to ride
and so that stuck in my head and when we
decided to do the show i'm like i have
to uh
get my self-respect back and uh get on
mr mean
only you think of it that way that
um
can you tell us about that my favorite
thing you ever wrote for big brother
magazine which was where uh
you had um
you you were posing as an agent prank
calling professional skateboarders oh
right
and getting them to do like silly
right campbell soup commercials
yeah yeah yeah he was calling like the
biggest names in skateboarding saying
i'm an agent and i've got you know i've
got something i think he'd be perfect
for and it was just like the worst look
of you know pitching them like you know
and would you be comfortable with your
shirt off like you know at the end of
these pro skaters and say oh yeah
totally man like he was saying how do
you look with your shirt off like you
got me i'm pretty ripped
dude it was that was the funniest thing
ever man
and uh and you said that that back in
the day that they're you know
with the partying i i'm pretty amazed
that that you seem to have just put it
down you know like all of the the you
know the crazy pills and the whiskey and
yeah no i still have drinks now now and
again uh but
the pills i put down um
and
did you have to do anything to put put
them down
was it just like probably when you have
kids you probably want to tone it down a
bit right yeah sure yeah well i mean
with madison like it kind of was the
opposite
you know i i wouldn't he wasn't ready
yet i wasn't ready yet and like i
wouldn't because i would see my father
drunk and i didn't want her to see me
drunk so i try not to
do that at home yeah right but i go out
and just get smashed
so i was yeah there were points in my
life where i was
partying way too much
yeah
um did i just kind of phase out or was
there a moment where like i gotta make a
change
um
it i think after
number two
you know and i yeah i got together with
naomi and and
started
uh
calming down then
yeah i would notice that because
on number two and you've said this
plenty that we were all on our absolute
worst oh my god
and everything that we did just worked
so like everything we did on camera like
just worked so well in that movie it was
like
god
and uh and
yeah you're uh three times all just
about behaving badly partying and then
four years later jackass 3d
like it just seemed like you
you had done an about phase you were a
totally different guy there was no
bad behavior there was no partying you
were just singularly focused on pouring
all of your time and energy into trick
nut shots
okay you really you traded when you
traded like one
i think that's fair i was uh
i would get obsessed with shooting
and
also i think
maybe it's a fair
thing to
put out there that i may have been
addicted to doing the larger stunts the
stunts that
really could take me out i think i got
really obsessed in that too which i'm
still coming out of
right right
because i know i can never get in with
another bull again
but
i physically miss it
if that makes sense i get it i get it
and and um
we just did the press junket for jackass
forever and um
it it like it seemed like we did
hundreds of interviews and it seemed
also that
a lot of the the questions from the
interviewers were like so this you know
this is it the swan song it's over
yeah and and i and i said well actually
after each and every one of the first
three jackass movies knoxville declared
on the record that it was over and this
fourth movie is actually the first time
he hasn't declared that i keep saying
like we may we might we might not but
there's no like
definitive answer but i i think these
reporters have to come in with some
angle right right so it's whatever i
understand i think what they're what
they're
interpreting
is uh
you're saying
that you're done
risking your life you can't get and get
in there with bulls anymore this is the
last movie that you're really going to
risk your life for right right and thank
god because i don't want you to
i don't i i never wanted to see you with
the bull in the first place i definitely
never want to see you with another bull
again
and if anybody reacts to your saying
that you know in any kind of a critical
way let me put it out there that it was
on
the third movie i showed up and i said
dude i'm not gonna risk my life i've
survived enough you know i've made it
this far i've lost my [ __ ] sense of
humor for being in a wheelchair or a
coffin right over a dumbass [ __ ]
jackass
i'm not doing it and i pretty much stuck
to my guns i said i said if uh if if
it's a risk of
paralysis or death i'm not doing it but
if there's not that risk then i'm in and
i don't think i backed out of anything
yeah no you i mean
if you didn't say that i don't think
anyone would realize it because you've
performed so great in jackass 3 and
forever so
well thanks man that now i showed up
with the same rules on
jackass forever
and one weekend i i called it that the
treadmill stunt was uh a real problem
for for the spine and the brain for
everybody
yeah i called it and i and i i
consciously deliberately
threw my rules out the window for that
you did yeah so i understand what you're
saying when you when you say that you
miss doing the physical stunts because
here i knew not to do that and
and how long were you out for when you
passed out
you know like
for like a minute or so you know the
duration of time that you're knocked
unconscious is a lot like uh the height
of bridges any [ __ ] whoever jumped
off at 20-foot bridge says oh man it was
100 feet you know like
and anybody's ever been knocked
unconscious oh man it was minutes five
minutes to it but like you timed the the
book yeah i i specifically timed the
bull and it was like about a minute five
seconds just because i want to know
right i want to know what happened to me
and um
uh
god there was a point that everybody
everybody was saying that you were out
for like five minutes no that's not true
it probably feels like that when you're
like is he gonna wake back up you have
no idea if you're knocked out you have
no concept of time right sure the only
way to know for sure is to go back and
watch the footage yeah because
my memory was erased for a little bit um
what's the difference when you pass out
like snoring or not snoring is like
snoring you're [ __ ]
out
says you're trying to swallow your
tongue
so
yeah cause you didn't snore did you i
snored with the bull and i snored with
butterbean yeah
i don't know if you snore on the
treadmill i i couldn't tell you i i
don't have any idea was this like you
know
recklessness
in character for you like when you
started doing this stuff for a big
brother and like if a friend who you
grew up with saw that would they be like
there he goes again or would they be
like whoa knoxville's like
a great question well i i you know
honestly i was a little rambunctious but
i wasn't the most
wild or rambunctious guy at the school
you weren't like let's jump off the roof
and let's [ __ ] do this no not really
yeah
but i mean the the people who knew you
when you were in high school in grade
school and they saw you on jackass where
they're like wave where'd this go no no
it wasn't it's not a shock to them
because i was a loudmouth and you know
was always in some some kind of trouble
but
uh
it wasn't that big of a shock but i
wasn't the wildest or
by far
the toughest but i mean that's the thing
about jackass none of us are that tough
right so it's like i think that's what
people can connect with this we're not
some manchester guys out there trying to
uh
you know uh
that there is
uh
an every man
well i mean we are every man and uh but
i will say about the treadmill
it could have been less
that the results could have been a
little better for our heads but there
was a pad down right before we filmed
like a rubber mat down
and i just said lose it for sure because
it's just when you see pads on the
jackass set it doesn't work
and
right do i regret it
no you know we're all okay but i have to
maintain
the sure remember after that dave
england called me up he's like hey dude
just a heads up like steve hit his head
pretty hard meanwhile i got texts from
steve booking a tour to austin and he's
like i'm like wait a minute what's going
on here
you had this whole tour going on you're
like okay let's get this guy on the road
and i'm like
dave just told me that you were out and
you're like yeah i'm in the hospital
yeah he booked the tour hardest working
man in show business right here for sure
it's possible uh um
you know i i would like to take this
moment to
to let everybody know how awesome the
jackass slingshot game is oh the jackass
human slingshot on mobile game yes
you can get that on google play or the
app store so it's actually a lot of fun
yeah
if you have an iphone you go to the app
store and you type in
jackass human slingshot that'll do it
and if you have an android you go to the
i have no idea
yeah and and in either which way you're
an absolute idiot if you don't do that
yes thank you steve all right now i'm
interested yeah i gotta go and and you
know and plus dude look at this
shirt i'm wearing just people listening
can't see it but i'm wearing the the
dickhouse shirt with the rainbow i mean
this is an iconic
american treasure the the dickhouse logo
and only just recently did dick house
start selling merch
yeah we we sold it like kind of low-key
but never in a focused way that we have
now what do you guys want to talk about
the thing with the thing with the pink
with you guys together and the yeah
we've got uh
like tony soprano over here
yes we
you had never signed merch to sell ever
once in your life and and then all of a
sudden i designed this skateboard with
that it's half me happier and this great
design
now let me tell you if you're gonna go
and get one of these skateboards that
we're talking about which both johnny
knoxville and i signed a lot of people
will you know how it's going to get
shipped to you
with ship station this is the secret
behind all of my merchandising operation
is that we ship everything so easily at
the best possible rates and just
fast and efficient ship station i'm
telling you man it's e-commerce these
days if you're not in the e-commerce
game then you're blowing it dude because
this is how i am rising above man i'm
not going to get away with doing what i
do forever and so i'm trying to sock
away some cash so that i'll be taken
care of later and i'd like for you to do
the same and if you want to ship more
stuff
easier
cheaper
faster
ship station's the way to go i swear to
you this is how i ship everything from
stevo.com and you know i'm always
promoting that stuff so i'm going to
give you a 60-day free trial with
shipstation and this like interface that
you're going to be using no matter what
you sell from if it's on amazon if it's
on etsy if it's you got your own little
website every different platform
seamlessly integrates on shipstation's
interface it is so easy and it is so
helpful plus they give you rates with
all the different carriers that are
normally reserved for fortune 500
companies you're going to be shipping
everything way cheaper
and like i said a 60 60 day free trial
if you go to shipstation.com
now when you get there you're going to
click the microphone in the top right
you click that you're gonna type in the
promo code stevo and you are set up to
get to shipping
like using it for free for 60 days
telling you it is time to make some
money so
go to shipstation.com
click the microphone in the top right
type in the promo code stevo and make
ship happen
yeah dude now let's get back to the game
how did i talk you into signing those um
i don't know it was a really great
graphic and we'd never
done anything like that before and i
thought it would be fun
it's
so cool that you know like i look at
that i've got i've got one up on the
wall and my my edit bay this skateboard
and you know have that like the left
side of the face is you and then the
right side of the face is me
and uh god i love it and we only have a
little bit left so they better go get
them right yeah and you check it out
yeah the johnny or skateboard you guys
got some signings
but yeah
yeah yeah you you haven't practiced your
signature a whole lot because sometimes
you sign at coxville sometimes you sign
it at knoxville well it's just my poor
penmanship yeah you know
the end slips away a little bit like
when i was in grade school like i would
get straight a's except for penmanship
it would be solid c or c minus yeah you
ran like a pharmacist yeah yeah
tell us about uh your baseball career
like that's a little known fact todd
that you were like a hardcore baseball
guy yes i love baseball and when i was
moving out here was like am i going to
go
try and play baseball uh honestly i
probably went to a junior college first
uh i could have played in junior college
or
and eventually maybe have made
a move up
uh positioned to division one
but yeah picture
but i already like i was coming out here
for the american academy dramatic arts
and my senior year i kind of blew my
elbow out uh we still had a great season
but i was like god i need to get out of
here i need to get out of knoxville
because i thought like i was just
i'm probably gonna get in trouble
if i stay yeah most of my friends either
got in trouble or became cops there's
like
three or four that you know
thrived
um
so
for people who maybe don't know
knoxville is not your birth last name
when did you adopt the name johnny
knoxville like when did that when i
started writing for magazines i didn't
want to write under pj clapp
[Laughter]
phillip john clapp yeah
like i don't want to read that guy
giant knoxville isn't it and uh
and so
when uh
one of the stunts that you did for for
big brother
and and i don't even know if you guys
were cooking up the idea of jackass yet
but you you tried with zero
skateboarding skills you tried to drop
in on a half pipe like a 10 foot tall
vert ramp right and you might as well
have just jumped off the deck and
straight to the flat bottom sideways
right on your shoulder because that's
what happened uh it was the most brutal
slam ever and it was just absolutely
fantastic
well my fear was if i under commit i'm
just going to slide down on my back
so
i didn't want to waste anyone's time so
i just stepped off the cliff
you didn't waste anybody's time it was
the most brutal slam and and i'd heard
that someone said that
for like years after that that your
shoulder was really messed up from that
slam and that like you had trouble like
turning the steering wheel of your car
like you couldn't make a left-hand turn
in your car because of that
possibly i remember having trouble
driving my car after the
butterbean ko because it gave me vertigo
okay and when i would
lay my [ __ ] my head to the side to lay
down the room would span if i drive
around a curve
the you know the car would spin
so i had to get on some medication for
that it took a while to wear off uh but
it's possible yeah
sure like sometimes you get hurt and
it's tough to drive your car
you uh
you told you said that you lost your
sense of smell
yeah i have to be right up on something
to smell it and it's not that great so
my sense of taste is probably compromise
my nose has been busted a few times so i
said that should you attribute that i
believe so otherwise i don't have any
idea
and then there was a point uh the way
where your back was super compromised
right like on jackass 3d we had like a
professional
like uh
what was the guy with the massage table
yeah yeah um it's just a basically a a
chiropractor who could
because what my back i blew my back out
at the end of
jackass number two i would just be
walking down the street and my back
would seize up and i'd fall over
after a bit no no no this is just
movie's over i'm trying to live my life
and my back would seize up and if
someone wasn't there to help me i would
just fall over wow um
because i
uh herniated a disc in my lower back and
when my
uh body when these psoas muscles they're
like big sausage muscles
here would detect that
detect pain back there they tried to
protect it
and
they would get really hard
to put up a barrier around it but when
that happened it would just pull me to
the ground
so
what i did is i got on an exercise
regime and found a chiropractor who
would just
stick his thumb right in those muscles
and they would release and after that i
was a new man
and i found a really good i found the
best anti-inflammatory
but
but actually that
diclofenac is so that actually did help
a lot
so
through exercise and the
anti-inflammatory uh it's it's
pretty good now every now and then i
have to get the chiropractor come and
release it but
uh it's all right
um
the the i remember when i was in in 2008
i was in rehab and uh you came to to
visit me just to show love and support
it meant so much
there was one uh
visit where you showed up and and you
had like
the full like your hair had grown out i
was like whoa knoxville's got gray hair
and that was that was 2008. yeah i let
it go gray for a little while i just got
sick of it
and
but madison told me that she liked it
dark and so i started coloring my hair
my daughter madison told me she liked
the dark so i started coloring my hair
again
i remember so when did uh
when did you start when did you first
color your hair
my late 20s that's crazy man yeah i was
going gray
soon my dad was completely white-haired
at 19.
wow yeah
steve martin yeah
wow that that's crazy man and uh
yeah i mean it have you handled the this
all this
what do you call it the reveal like uh
i think you had a fun way of describing
all of a sudden uh revealing the gray
hair silver foxville oh yeah
no i yeah i can't remember what i said
but there's something about
uh i can't remember it yeah i remember
writing you something about
right but and it just seems with full
confidence like
i think that uh
i'm so much more of a sensitive like uh
you don't like going gray i enjoy it
yeah steve doesn't like aging at all
nothing about it on aging yeah well
you're in that uh
i think everyone gets a little bummed on
aging but you're in that place where
it's just a little gray right so you're
just coming to terms with it i had many
years to come to terms with it i knew
what was under here you know yeah yeah
so so was that like a very freeing like
acceptance of
growing old or just even
like we've never been grey on camera
before have you
yeah was that hard to do
no i was so i did feel liberated because
like i have to go every three weeks
to get my hair colored and after a
couple of weeks it would start you'd see
the white everywhere and it's just a
drag
right so it's like a lot of work it's a
lot of work yeah
and um who thought we'd be talking about
hair coloring on this
but it's but it's true but i'm psyched
i'm so happy with
that i don't have to color it anymore
and i like look look what happens it
looks like what that oh
i've only seen really uh
positive feedback about it yeah i i
think it's great do you guys have a
favorite bit of the new jackass do you
guys have uh i i want to say how
impressive it is to me that the of all
the jackass guys
nobody lost their hair
yeah that's true we don't even have any
like
legit bald spots yeah
although they're when i had my dark hair
in the beginning of the movie there is a
little like uh
quarter-sized thing that spike took care
of never had a problem with it after
that
yeah and uh the the new movie god
covered screwed up movie theaters but
now
uh if anybody's paying attention to the
news the the story is that that
everybody's lifting the mask mandates
kobe is in such sharp decline like for
the love of god movie theaters are back
this weekend and it's time for everybody
to get to the damn movie theater right
yeah fingers crossed this downturn keeps
going down because the world just not
just everyone's been through it the
whole world's been through it i don't
know what's going to happen but i'm just
riding the wave that the numbers are
down and everyone can get to the ears
and enjoy the movie safely because
there's 300 theaters closed last week
for over the weekend because of this no
there's a snowstorm or something right
it was like a state of emergency in like
26 states from new mexico to maine i was
like come on like what the [ __ ] on our
opening weekend we gotta have the whole
country snowed in with ice and sleet and
and states of emergency hopefully that's
not going on this weekend yeah and
hopefully everybody's heard how
ridiculously good jackass forever is
it's a critical darling it's crazy that
the critics finally
like us you know i think we got a little
that on jackass 3d and a little bit on
bad grandpa
and it's been so long since we made it
this is just my guess i don't i don't
know anything about anything i don't
know [ __ ] from apple butter
but i think the critics now who are
riding were in high school when the
first jackass came out and they have a
fond memory of it and now they're in
charge right they're running it so
and i think also that i think we did a
pretty good job with the film so i think
it's a mix of those two things but
could be other things yeah i think for
the old school mind it was probably hard
to see what you guys do as like sort of
an art form and like sort of the beauty
of the image of what it is but now it's
like [ __ ] are we making art i think so i
don't know that
yeah it's like there's such a branded
look and feel of jackass too that's like
obviously very authentic it's not like
something you guys sat down and wrote
down but i've always been curious
actually there's like a i edit steve's
videos so like i'm you know
like
when did the you know you guys say a
thing blah blah yeah good and then
everyone walks off camera and the like
the walk off camera after you've like
said your funny thing is kind of like
jackass branded
thing i don't know that always happens
but there's definitely like if you get
the sense that you've just put a button
on something you're walking we have the
instinct to get out of frame yeah like
did that i don't know when did that
start or did you have any well all i
know is like
when i did the self-defense equipment
article for the video i introduced
myself i'm giant knoxville united states
of america and i introduced what i was
going to do in the bit
and
when we did the tv show spike said you
should introduce yourself every time he
really liked it i'm like all right
spike knows better than me for sure that
man is so great so that's what started
like hi i'm stevo this is the butt
chugger yes because spike's idea really
even though the first time um
the the first thing i did that for was
the goldfish and i couldn't do it so
knoxville said hi i'm johnny knoxville
and this is stevo and he's going to do
the gold gears trick because you're
nervous on camera i was so nervous i was
useless on camera for for the longest
time now we can't get him to shut up
you know what but he went when i was
particularly useless when it was on
airplanes
oh god
you and pontius man on airplanes were
the like why because you're just so
[ __ ] up
yeah i mean you didn't sleep for five
days before and then you went on an
airplane you know what i want to do i
want to make a youtube video about the
truth of gumball rally oh man
oh man is right you are about to get a
juicy scoop on the truth of gumball
rally where we were really choking our
chickens of course no chickens were
harmed on gumball rally and no chickens
were harmed in the making of just egg
this is made from plants it's a bottle
that you get at the supermarket and it
comes with this liquid egg
program you pour it into the frying pan
you make decadent delicious scrambled
eggs egg sandwiches quiche it's super
healthy too man zero cholesterol and in
fact it's got cholesterol lowering
polyunsaturated fat i'm telling you
chicken eggs wish they were this healthy
for you it's totally delicious man it's
an exciting new product and i want you
to go find it at the grocery store man
it's out there it's epic they
need you to know about it because it's
that healthy it's for good people and if
you're a good person you're gonna try it
now let's hear about gumball rally
[ __ ] show wait wait yeah but it was this
this thing that they do every year with
like a bunch of just obnoxiously wealthy
people and all these luxury cars and
they just pick
some
journey to go on for us it was we raced
cars with millionaires from london to
russia and back in a huge circle through
12 countries some billionaires yeah
max cooper puts it together but i
remember like you would think it's a
bunch of millionaires and billionaires
and
but but they had pretty good spirit
they're pretty good spirits oh for sure
yeah it's the fun ones yeah totally i
mean if you're doing something like that
these guys want to
like
pedal to the metal so that was that was
a jackass special and like how did that
even come up like uh i was
i'd gone to london
with um
mike ballard okay right
to film
the me getting shot out of a cannon in
brixton
and my friend john morales drove us to
brixton but he john had a friend max
cooper max cooper comes over and said
hey
i'm just getting this i've done this a
couple times this gumball rally thing do
you guys want to do it and so i took it
to jeff and spike and they thought it
would be fun and did mtv go for it right
away
oh i don't remember i think at that time
mtv was pretty happy like
to do what i mean the show was doing
good so right so so we start out and
it's it's knoxville
and and
me and pontius in the car
with like one one other person ponies
and i are in the back seat
gooch was driving and someone else maybe
dimitri was in the front seat
they had this big ceremony in the middle
of uh like hyde park in in london
they're blowing up fireworks all these
and start and all these luxury cars
taking off
as soon as they start this this race
pontius and i
just started jacking up
and i was between them
you know i'm in the bag but point
between them you don't see it as bad
enough why i think you were in the front
i think it was just german not in the
back
we decided that we were going to have a
a contest to see who could blow the most
loads in the car while it was moving and
full of dudes and uh
and we've rubbed ourselves raw
like just leaving london they were like
double decker buses like looking down on
us like you know as they passed and uh
it wasn't until the dead of night when
when i got my uh when i got it done
and i remember which is really weird for
you because uh
right did it take that long that means
your first load you blew
yeah yeah and and by the time i blasted
that one there was just something about
being in the car full of dudes and of
course you know like yeah you know it
was only when everybody was only once
everybody was asleep except for the
driver was i able to to get it done and
i blasted this window so that i wake up
knoxville i'm like hey knoxville wake up
dude film this and and i could make
knoxville film i'm like pan from me and
ask me what's that on the window and i
had shot it all over the window
and uh and then like the next morning
knoxville switched cars yeah
by the time we got to france i was out
of there
had fun
2018 b team kind of a thing yeah i was
who won
uh tied four loads a piece
at the end wow it was i mean their
windows looked like a krispy kreme
doughnut it was just oh and it's the
smell
oh god
that bleachy [ __ ] smell
for sure when
because we made sure we documented every
single load and mtv didn't even show one
yeah
my goodness the indignities this man has
had to face but in the history of
jackass there's very like little that
didn't
make it
somewhere somewhere yeah you know too
hot for tv or right right you can kind
of count them on uh yeah i made a video
and i put it on youtube and included
some of the things that i was like oh
yeah this wasn't even allowed on tv and
then like with within a very short time
of me posting that video i received a a
strike
from from youtube oh really yeah how
many strikes you get you had three
strikes and your channel is deleted
for is there like it's deleted for a
year or
it's deleted it's deleted forever but
like
a strike puts you on probation for like
a certain amount of time and then the
strike will
will go away so how does that work do
you now run your stuff by youtube before
you post it um
it would be nice if everybody could do
that but uh you really got to just kind
of you know
censor yourself a little bit yeah maybe
you'll be you'll be kind of careful
until the strike goes away this this
happened a while back oh so how long do
you keep the strike for it's not
lifetime
it's not forever no the strike will go
away after like i want to say 90 days or
something okay so so you don't have to
like walk on eggshells too bad is that
your only strike uh i've had a three i
had a warning and then two strikes and
the two strikes went away but the
warning stays i think
there was the hot sauce you can get it
at stevo.com on amazon
and uh because we put it up in my butt
and we really showed it like putting it
going in my butt and like me pooping
everywhere i was kind of like in
hindsight that was we're number three
yeah
we're number three on amazon right now
fyi yeah with your uh hot sauce yeah
that's great well the first like one and
it caught me off guard i i put the the
best um
the best wake-up pranks of jackass and
wild boys i thought we're like what a
fun video you know like whenever
the mamba and we slapped people in there
you were pure hell to wake up yeah you
woke up spitting and wanting to fight
yeah for sure the only time i was ever
tough is right when you wake me up yeah
yeah
then he calms down real quick but man he
comes out swinging and he jumped out
that window
didn't like the wake up pranks because
um it's like assaulting somebody who's
not consenting you know like
they're sleeping yeah they're sleeping
and they can't consent and you're
hitting them it's like an assault yeah
but i mean you're filming with us so
you're kind of consenting walking on the
stairs but i understand that was my
insured of the whole video i was like
you know i'm falling asleep on the very
irresponsible dude
you just want footage yeah you're
begging for it but but then then i got
the strike for the one and i showed it
too box downstairs i i was like all
right that was just so simple and dumb
could have been terrible oh it could
have been terrible knoxville got in a
[ __ ]
cardboard box with like a couple pillows
cardboard box they tape it up close and
then just knock it down the stairs end
over it don't don't don't don't don't
down all these cement stairs it was a
i don't know what i was thinking you
know i you know i'd been i just came off
a film right and the guys have been kind
of carrying the load and i hadn't been
able to do a lot of dangerous stuff
because i had been doing a film and then
i was like i got to get back into
the swing of things and get everyone's
respect in my mind that's why i was like
i had lost respect by doing this film so
i'm like i might as well come out
swinging
and
oh man i went it goes
skip skip and then it takes a big jump
and all the impact i absorbed on my
lower back it just slammed and that just
felt like pure hell i probably uh
started my lower back problems right
there yeah box downstairs and it was
like counterintuitive because you could
you got to like just trust that you're
in the box he can't see you
right right right no without it being
like uh a one long
take without any cuts like you know you
could have like i mean but nobody that's
that's
nobody doubts us never nobody doubts us
and what was the the other okay there
there was uh i'm johnny knoxville and
i'm gonna get hit by a car real soon oh
yeah that was from the big brother video
i think
poop
i don't know yeah i'm sure like like
can't put it on youtube so people
probably don't even know about it yeah
yeah the car like when they see that
uh i don't know the buckle is sure if
they get there early they can see it but
what was your strategy with the car
because it hits you but then you like
end up on top of it like a cat through
the windshield over onto the roof the
car never slows down yeah
my oh my only thing i wanted to do was
get up on the hood i didn't want to have
my knees taken out right yeah so i just
tried to get up on the hood and after
that
that car was hauling it's the most epic
[ __ ] shot he says i'm johnny
knoxville and i'm going to get hit by a
car real soon he's standing in the
middle of the road and showing up the
car just comes goes blowing right
through the frame he goes through the
windshield the car never stops and and
and later somebody asked you there was a
quote in big brother like what what were
you thinking standing there getting hit
by a car ed knoxville's answer was oh
well i wore two pairs of jeans so i'd be
safe
i i
i think i was totally
serious because i there i do have those
irrational ways to think that i'm safe i
remember when i was doing the python or
the anaconda ball pit i was like man
what i have to avoid here
is the snake biting my wrists and
severing my arteries so you put on that
i put a strip electrical tape around my
wrist
and in my head it was like
it was safe
but little did i know after i filmed
that bit the guy was like yeah one of
these anacondas took off someone's calf
muscle last week
but in my head that was that electrical
tape saved me it was your suit of armor
yeah yeah yeah and and another one was
when you when you shot yourself with the
smith and wesson 38 caliber handgun
and you're wearing like a used 300
bulletproof vest you tucked some porno
magazines under it yeah yeah yeah yeah
thinking that was going to help it
wasn't it was a brand new vest but it
was the cheapest one they made god yeah
i had some leg worlds up there whatever
flint had whatever tremaine got from
flint just laying around and and you
said there was a shot
it was on camera like you're trying to
shoot yourself in porto magazines or
falling out of the
bush out and then i've been over to pick
it up and so i'm stepping back in and i
have the gun pointed right at the camera
it's just so
irresponsible wow
was it by design that you just put one
bullet in the gun so that you would have
the suspenseful like click click
i put it wasn't by design just to put
one bullet in the gun but it
the the hole it going around i thought
it was like going to be one shot and
over but i didn't know anything about
guns so all the way around
but it helped yeah oh my god that
footage is intense
i i'm trying to think okay so another
one that was never allowed to see the
light of day
and it was genius was uh
the hardware store all right yeah yeah
tell us about that one
um
i put on a prison orange jumpsuit
and
get handcuffed and get my hair all dirty
and my face full of mud and i go in the
hardware store out of breath and i'm
like oh can you help me get these off
you know referring to the handcuffs you
have a hacksaw
oh yeah yeah yeah and we did that once
just
randomly right me spike jeff and
someone else and we didn't have any
camera hides or anything and but like he
got a huge reaction and like four or
five card loads of cops show up
and they all have their guns out and
spike and jeff are like what do we do do
we take off or
you know
the best footage was that one of the
cops
pulls up like it screams in the in the
frame or the footage is great the cop
gets out of their car but doesn't put it
in parks so this cob jumps out of the
car and the cards this cop car just
continues and crashes into a [ __ ]
like a telephone pole yeah
that was the second time we did it yeah
and the car that's
the cops came both times you did it yeah
the cops came both times we did it but
it wasn't covered because we didn't know
what we were getting into right and we
didn't know
but so it's poorly covered and we had to
do it again and the second time that's
when the cop didn't put her car in park
and it hit the telephone pole and by
that time i was on the ground with my
hands out here i'm like oh no we're
really in trouble now
she goes up to knoxville laying there
with her gun on she says why aren't you
in jail right
and
god and she told me afterwards she goes
if you would have moved one little bit
or tried to get away i would put the
bullet in your ear so yeah so i knew
like when cops drew their guns just do
what they say yeah um and i asked her
afterwards i'm like was this the oddest
call you've ever been on she goes no i
had one guy
bug naked up the top of a palm tree and
he was on uh
like pcp or something and he slid all
the way down the palm tree balls and all
right oh
he was straight to the middle hospital
yeah flawless
was there any punishment for the bit
like did you get i seem to recall that
there was a lawsuit that was settled for
like five thousand bucks uh our one of
our producers got arrested metha meta
got arrested
and i regretted that because
i was on the set i was the one who
should have got arrested but i really
didn't know how things worked and uh
but that was taken care of and uh why'd
she get arrested because she was her
name was on the they're like who's
producing here who's producing here and
she's the one who stepped up yeah so one
of my favorite bits in it i'm not sure
if it's on the jackass but certainly the
big brother was uh when you ordered the
eggs and bacon
you scratched the bacon out and you put
[ __ ] down
there my sausage looks like poop
yeah that's a good bit yeah up until
then i had been doing stunts and that
was the first prank i did and i don't
know why that was why i thought of that
but
it's so good i'm trying to think of it
like there's really very little that
that that couldn't ever see the light of
day i got branded the heart over my
heart they said they wouldn't show
sizzling smoking flesh
see we said you could get branded well
yeah we said you could you could shoot
it but we didn't say anything about
airing footage of sizzling smoking flesh
what the [ __ ] do you think branding is
yeah yeah
the vomit didn't get aired yeah the
vomit yeah with dave england uh even
though the reshoot of it did yeah yeah
but the original was much funnier
because it was one of it's one of those
ideas where yeah it's like the super
glue
from jackass number two it was a rainy
day and what we wanted to shoot was we
could no longer shoot and right dave
england said hey i can eat all the
ingredients for an omelette and then
puke it up into a frying pan frying pan
and cook it and then
how you you volunteered
to to eat it
it was just a [ __ ] show and florida the
moon's hot yeah manny was there manny
loved that [ __ ] so much yeah
the naming of bits is always like
crucial like yeah vomit or
whatever the first time you met manny
you uh
like you were like okay like i want to
get bitten by a rattlesnake
man he says you can't do that right and
you're like really pushing for it no no
like just let the rattlesnake bite me
and we learned that when manny
says uh
no
that that means [ __ ] no yeah yeah if
manny's sketchy about it then it's like
all right all right because when manny
says yes that doesn't necessarily mean
you're good
what was that when you were getting you
were before the uh you're hanging out
over the alligator pit and what was his
safety plans
he says if an alligator gets a hold of
stevo stevo will relax and hopefully the
alligator will release him
[Laughter]
he's so great i remember like one of the
it might have been the first time i ever
filmed with with with uh manny when we
went out to do the hammerhead thing it
was the first well the first day on the
with sharks and manny and uh
they chopped barracuda
in half and and strung them all up and
like bloody and just
chum
chopped up barracuda fish strapped all
over me
and and then manny put me in the water
with the sharks
[Laughter]
yeah and i remember my dad decided my
dad says how could it possibly be safe
to be covered in chum swimming with
sharks and i looked at dad like
dad manny was there god
god
i might
get off my case yeah [ __ ]
manny's like my little uh force field
yeah that's how i feel about uh
gary lefew with the ball i mean i feel
that way about manny too he's he he's
just he's tarzan right right and you do
feel even though you're doing something
[ __ ]
you do feel like somewhat safe just
because he's there
and the same way with gary lefew with
bulls for sure uh
i just always feel like he's well he
always he's always got my back and he
always has he hires the best bull
fighters uh because they're crucial
because if you go you get ko
and uh you're alone in the ring with the
bull it it could be even worse
yeah for sure there was a time where
everyone's gonna know this with manny we
put the fish hooks through my face and
cast me out to the sharks manny's
manny's chopping up the you know he's
just
chumming the water treading water
hacking up fish
and he sees this maker shark going after
me like it's gonna bite my foot and one
of the very few times manny ever became
uncomfortable while filming like i heard
he screams stephen watch out right and
and
i hear that and so i'm like [ __ ] i panic
and i go to like you know kicking to go
swim away and in that motion i
inadvertently kick the maker shark in
the head as it's going for my foot yeah
which was like arguably one of the
closest calls i've ever had yeah and and
i think
it was like years later i asked jeff
tremaine i said jeff dude if that maker
sharp bit my foot
we were
two hours away from the the coast of
hurricane katrina devastated louisiana
like what the [ __ ] was the plan like
like a helicopter i mean like what and
and tremaine said oh we didn't have a
plan we got god
like how do you explain how lucky we've
been i well i was in arkansas getting
ready to do the riot control test
and i was talking to jeff and
talking about casting you out to sea
with the hook through your mouth chummed
up waters with sharks
and i was like jeff what what is the uh
how does
what's the best case scenario of this
because
how's it going i mean if we get footage
that means something terrible has
happened and
how do we air that like what are we
going for here and he's like oh no it'll
be great i'm like
i really had questions about that so it
was one of those things where right it
couldn't have went any better like you
didn't get hurt but you almost got
annihilated you almost were missing the
foot right i mean like it's like great
jeffy you've explained the the beginning
in the middle but yeah
at the end there's only one way for this
to end for it to air right i remember
being troubled by that bit but i wasn't
so troubled that i said don't do it
i did i did have pause i was thinking of
your steve
right yeah and it was the same thing
with the alligator tightrope i i as i
understood it my job for the alligator
tightrope i was like oh yeah and then
tomorrow i'm getting bit by an alligator
like i'm going to walk on the table fall
off and then in the alligator pit and
then i get bit
yeah
yeah and that was another one i remember
feeling like not getting bit by the
alligator and it just taking the chicken
out of the jog strap
to me that like felt the way you
described getting on a social sociable i
was like oh man like you know i've lost
my respect i showed up to get attacked
by an alligator no no but that was great
you didn't even
because you could have yeah you very
well could have and you stuck it out and
you did all you needed to do yeah so i
mean that's a great bit yeah and in
hindsight i'm not i'm not upset about it
but uh but i remember thinking oh i
really got away with one today yeah yeah
um what uh
yeah what are some of the other like
just crazy like where we've got angels i
mean i i i think about dragons and i
really believe that they're not like the
rocket for the rocket yeah it not only
almost killed me but one rocket goes out
back like
150 yards and goes right between
kassick and scott manning's ear is just
shut and that would have decapitated one
of them or both of them it was a foot
long metal rod
that was an angel um the the steel wall
falling on me at the end of jackass
number two
because the the guy who rigged it is
like
you get to your mark don't move it's a
this is a this is a steel wall you will
die if it hits you
and then
what happened that's like travis
pastrana telling you not to let go of
the bike
i'm not listening like before i do a
stunt i don't sometimes i i you can be
talking to me but you can see in my eyes
and i'm far away
you know
i remember seeing the wall hit you
thinking like that was
that was the bit you know like no no
that wasn't supposed to happen wow and
uh
i remember on the set
i had
uh my daughter come down because i
thought this is like no one's gonna get
hurt today we're just
it's pretty casual and then at that door
that steel wall slammed me and it goes
silent on the set except for madison and
she goes dad what are you doing you
idiot
everyone started laughing after that
because
you know i moved around a little so oh
wow yeah and and like that the golf cart
with uh yeah that could have been that
was almost real bad yeah
that was
i feel like for
for years after that the golf cart was
referred to as the incident
yeah like that good because that one was
really really scary but yeah we've been
we've been incredibly fortunate man
we've had a lot of incidents
and uh
you know this is something that
with the concussions i tell you know i
can't say it enough i [ __ ] hate when
when you get in front of bulls even on
jackass number two like in the footage
in that that movie i'm just like i'm so
visibly like not okay with it i never
was okay with the bulls and um
with the
you know
all the the butter bean with the the on
your action point like there's been so
many concussions you know who's super
worried about
your uh concussions is dr drew
right i don't know like why he's privy
to like the the extent of your uh
concussion history but he but he's he
seems to be well aware of it and highly
concerned and i think that he
exacerbated my concerns so
you know i said this to uh to the men's
health reporter i was like you know like
with uh knoxville's brain
and my dad being
78 years old
like
everything my dad says every
conversation i'm like scanning it you
know like it's like like like please god
don't let there be any dementia coming
in and i do the exact same thing with
knoxville like every text every
conversation like is that has
has the concussions [ __ ] up his brain
like you know is he still there
and uh you and my dad like
have uh
you know never never faltered yeah my
brain was [ __ ] up for a while after
the this last one it was for a few
months that
i
it was scrambled yeah i mean dude the
treadmill was nothing compared to that
bullhead and and i had headaches and and
irritability and [ __ ] memory problems
for like three weeks after the treadmill
yeah no i
it was
you know i got all kinds of cognitive
tests and just scored so low on most
every
thing i i the
neurologist is like did you have trouble
paying attention i was like yeah
you know because i was trying to edit
and i couldn't sit still right and
he's like because you scored a 17
on the uh attention portion of the
and i was like out of 20 he's like out
of 100
out of 20.
forever optimus
eventually because it just started
it just started spiraling downwards and
the antidepressants helped reset my
brain
so uh
and you know time
time helped my brain to heal and recover
wow but uh
didn't mean to bring the show down
when a doctor's giving you kind of bad
news like that or bleak news at least
like are you you're able to stay
optimistic or do you get like were you
actually kind of scared like [ __ ] maybe
this is like
not gonna get better uh a little scared
but i am pretty much
an optimist so i just have to
believe that i'm going to get better
even like when i was a kid with asthma
i'd be in and out of the hospital all
the time right
and couldn't breathe have to spend the
night in the hospital
i just kept thinking i'm going this is
going to get better this is going to get
better because it's pretty scary right
when you're a little kid and like i
almost died when i was eight
but i just think
thought like [ __ ] it i'm like everyone
else and i'm just i just got to get
through this jackass four and theaters
everywhere
in the world everybody get to the
theater man i'm gonna say this in the
intro too i've got to man like like the
the covid numbers plummeted [ __ ] it's
okay to go to the movies it's everywhere
around the world
yeah there's not everywhere yet but
it's done really well around the world
yeah it's doing really well it's really
really good we want you to go see it we
want you to be wearing a dickhouse shirt
when you go and see it so
so get that dick house shirt we should
probably put those on your website too
right like we said
i took photos with will fox wearing them
and then we'll put the johnny o boards
right behind those yeah yourself
both knoxville and i signed these
special johnny o skateboards get
yourself one of those
get you the get the mobile game the
jackass slingshot
boombox
have said this sooner but but i say this
often and i mean it every time
which is that
i can't thank you enough and i can't
express enough gratitude
just in general like how much it means
to me that in all of my little
like uh side projects all my little
stevo things like how you've always
taken the time to
to to read my books to watch my videos
to critique my comedy specials like no
matter what the project is
everything i've ever sent you and asked
you for feedback not only have you taken
the time to really really check out the
project but you've given like very
thoughtful constructive
feedback and and you didn't ever have to
do that and and you doing that like it
makes me feel so emotional like i could
just cry because because your support in
in doing that for me uh [ __ ] it it means
the world to me well i love you and i'm
proud of you and i'm happy to see you
flourishing and you know so um happy to
do it i love you and i love you buddy
i love you so much man your opinion
matters so much to me you're uh
you're like you're a big brother figure
you're a hero
you're uh you're the captain man and um
you know
everything good in my life really came
from you my sobriety my career
well
like i helped in some areas but none of
this would happen if it hadn't been for
you right you took responsibility you
kicked the ass you stayed committed like
what
i gave you nudges a couple of times but
you're the one who took the
uh bull by the horns i think that works
here
and that's what's so impressive like
there's a lot of people that have
you know have uh chemical
dependency issues or whatever they're
dealing with and they can never
they can never get it licked but like
credit to you you know you
not only have
taken care of that but i've never seen
you better in your whole life well thank
you man um
you got me started in every one of those
good things in my career and my sobriety
it was you who got me started and uh i'm
so grateful for that and and i really
think too that
that our relationship is is stronger
better closer
now than it ever has been before and
yeah that's accurate yeah we're
we're clear yeah right we're we're we're
absolutely clear
and uh you know i'm easier to be around
than i used to be still kind of tough
small doses is better
me too like i have my issues in uh
uh whereas
i would stay distracted with what i was
distracted with you would you were the
same way you were headed one way i was
always headed another and now it's like
we can sit and talk yeah i i love it so
much i love you thank you love you buddy
thank you for my life and my career
that's a little that's stretching it but
uh
it's a good way to end he's a showman
he's a showman people oh yeah i love it
goodnight everybody
that's just gotta make you feel good huh
i mean [ __ ] i love that dude i love that
it was a long time coming
and i'm so glad we finally made it
happen
sorry about those two weeks off too man
the the one week off
was just because we were so busy with
the movie and the press junket and
everything and then the week off after
that was because of the stupid covid you
know i [ __ ] tested positive for covid
and even if it looks like the test
didn't say positive in that video we put
out there's the faintest little thin
line on there
and uh that was the second positive so
yeah i mean
but nothing happened to me man i didn't
get sick
it was just a dumb test but whatever i i
digress i'm getting emotional
getting riled up uh thank you for
sticking around to the end you know i
love you and
get on over to stevo.com and get
yourself the johnny oh skateboard man
look at that thing dude it's sick
all right thanks everybody
i walk off camera like